imagine a world where organic farming
not only thrives but also brings in a
hefty profit enter the African
Nightcrawler your Garden's new best
friend these wriggly Wonders work
tirelessly beneath the surface turning
your kitchen scraps into nutrient Rich
vermiculite it's like magic but it's
science vermiculture the practice of
cultivating worms is an eco-friendly
costeffective method that's
revolutionizing the farming industry the
African Nightcrawler specifically is a
champion decomposer transforming waste
into a natural fertilizer that plants
love and the best part it's a fast
process meaning quicker crop turnover
and more money in your pocket so who's
ready to get their hands dirty and jump
into the world of organic farming with
these little helpers don't forget
subscribe for more organic farming tips
and tricks embrace the African
Nightcrawler Revolution today